Chúng ta đang nghe bà miếng một năm 2020, khoa hàng nhanh dân khu vực bà
tình của hàng nội đã tinh phản đường với hai bị gão với nhanh dân
hai bị tạm tuổi, chú xa ổ zin, hàng nội, và nguyên lòng vũ, hai bị bà tuổi,
chú xa hợp thích tình bất nền về tội tây dấu chực tự con cóp.
Thế đó, hợp đồng xe xù tên phạt bị gão với nhanh dân thân hai bị tư thần tuổi
bị gão với nòng vũ bị tên phạt xa ổ thần tuổi.
Quà muốn tháng trước, nguyên văn thiền có hình bì hút quốc, chỉ đạo đánh người tại một quân khá
phay tổ hô đồ thị tham city, hà đội của việc tuổi sẽ tâm của zülển xa hợp.
Hợp đồng xe xù nhận định tại phía tỏa, bị gão với nòng vũ, hai hình
tòm bộ hình bý phạm tội đúng như lự dụ dung cao trạm, phía định xe phạm
bà đến gỷ được xem xác xám dạy hình phản.
Chào tìm đó, bị gão với nhanh dân thân dụ tại phía tỏa vẫn quân cầu, không thù nhận hình bý phạm tự.
Sông cần cụ lời khai trong bộ xe vũ an, lời khai của bị gão với nòng vũ tại tỏa,
không lời khai của bị gói lợp, với vũ lình quan lại anh của mình đây, hợp đồng xe xù
xe định các chính cứ phù hợp có đồ cần cụ đồng cây xù.
Vô việc đồng xe xóo trông xa hợp anh của mình trong đến tình hình anh em chất tự trên địa bàn.
Sẽ cơ tình tích hợp đồng xe xù trà dòng việc chi tỏa xe xù là cơm thiết nhằm giữa
giúp sinh và phòng người chung.
Vô vời đi cao thiên dù không có tin an, tẻ sự như tại tỏa không thình khẩm khai báo,
không nhận thức só hình bý bạm pháp lột nên vụ đồng xe xù không a sự tình tích sả nhẹ.
Tình yên, sết hoang cạnh ra đến có bố đăng được xí trẻ thật,
hợp đồng xe xù xe xe xảm nhẹ một phòng hình phát.
Vô vời đi cao với lòng vũ, hợp đồng xe xù viện bị cao chức có tin an, tình dự phát tự lần đầu,
tuộc trường hợp ít nhìn chọt, quá trình con tác có thình tích và tình khẩm khai báo
tệ tòa đến được xe xảm nhẹ một phần hình phát.
Chứ đó, về kiểm sát đến gỡ đồng xe xù tình phát bi cào,
với văn tiến của bà mề đến bà mề sáng thằng tù về tự lần xe tự con cộp,
đi cao với lòng vũ tự tà mề bố thằng tù về cùng tổ dành.